we're live I'm just gonna give it a
second to let people connect already
from the thumbnail people saying hey
David you're wearing glasses what's up
with that yes I'm not lying
in those Warby Parker ads when I say
that I wear glasses my last pair of
contacts that I brought with me this
weekend ripped and I'm with the glasses
the rest of the weekend had to order
some new contacts and thought I had an
eyelash in my eye all night last night
turns out it was probably pieces of my
contact lens in any case those went
right in the trash and yeah wearing
glasses so I'm gonna talk about a bunch
of different stuff today once people
connect so yesterday I talked about that
bizarre Trump press conference it's been
followed up by an even weirder email
okay and I'm gonna get to that a little
bit later we now have learned obviously
we knew that Michael Flynn lied a number
of times about his conversation with the
Russian ambassador that ultimately led
to his resignation forced resignation of
course what we are now learning is that
Flynn also lied to the FBI and that
starts to get into the world of what we
call crime criminality and we're gonna
talk about that Trump approval ratings
two new polls one which says Trump's
approval rating is down and other which
says Trump's approval rating is up we'll
talk about that we are now learning that
I don't think anybody's going to be too
surprised by this we are now learning
also that there are questions about
Donald Trump's claims about his academic
achievements at the University of
Pennsylvania so we're going to talk
about that a little bit later somebody
sent me a craigslist post about money
being offered to show up publicly in
support of Trump On February 18th
tomorrow and questions about whether
that's true and also there are doctors
who say now that presidents are living
longer maybe we should actually be
testing for dementia and
although it might sound like this is
specifically related to Donald Trump and
it's not crazy to think that when I say
that they are talking a little bit more
broadly about that like I did like I've
been doing during these streams any new
members that sign up at david pakman.com
slash membership during the stream I
will give live shout outs and thank-yous
and on that note big thank you to Zen
and Dawson who just signed up at david
pakman.com slash membership and we do a
discount off of membership at ivote at
17 is the coupon code it'll work on any
membership on our website ok so I'm not
gonna rehash the entire Trump press
conference from from yesterday it was
insane there's like a 45-minute
livestream about that and we will talk
about that probably on the show the
coming week as well but so there's a
follow up to this which is that moments
after the press conference the Trump I
mean I don't know if you call it the
Trump campaign you may know that Donald
Trump officially filed for re-election
on Inauguration Day which has a number
of financial implications that we've
discussed but there was an email from
the Trump pence campaign which says
basically that the media is an enemy
they say friend you know that I don't
trust the media to report on anything we
achieve instead you the American people
are our last line of defense against the
media's hit jobs you are our greatest
asset in helping our movement deliver
the truth to the American people and
then it has a link which says I need you
to take the mainstream media
accountability survey to do your part to
fight back against the media's attacks
and deceptions so immediately the first
reaction from from progressives which is
not a crazy reaction was hey let's all
get together and fill this out in a way
that will completely distort whatever it
is that the Trump campaign is looking to
do some kind of confirmation bias
seemingly and then after that there was
follow-up from a few different
journalists who wrote articles saying no
don't do that because then they're gonna
have information on you you know that
we've looked at all the studies which
tell us that from people's IP address
even an anonymous survey done online
could still be providing enough metadata
so that you could be tracked
individually you could end up on some
list if you try to fill out the survey
in a way that's antagonistic to Trump so
listen I don't know ultimately what
people are doing I'm gonna give it the
weekend and then we'll see next week
what comes of this very strange account
media accountability survey from the
Trump campaign and I know people hear me
say the Trump campaign and they say well
but he's the president now campaign type
communications have not stopped since
Trump was inaugurated and just just a
lot of very very strange stuff in that
survey benjamin dickson show checking in
live i wonder if ben is that I know it's
Friday so he wouldn't be at David Pakman
show studios it's a mystery you never
know what what Benjamin Dixon is doing
he could be anywhere at any point in
time like I said I'll be doing live
shoutouts and thank-yous to people who
sign up at david pakman.com slash
membership during the stream big thank
you to Ellen Sherman Ellen Sherman who
just signed up at david pakman.com slash
membership and we do have a coupon code
which gives you a 40% discount it's I
voted 17 yesterday we had something like
36 people sign up during the live stream
at david pakman.com slash slash
membership which was which was big ok
let's talk a little bit about michael
Flynn
these are basically we have such a
unique situation right now we're in the
old days of the David Pakman show and by
that I mean like a year ago before the
era of Trump the night before the show I
would have you know five maybe six of
the next day's stories lined up and the
next day I would get up and I'd look at
the news and I'd sort of pick one or two
more stories for the show the amount of
insanity that's happening every single
night between I don't know midnight and
6 a.m. Eastern is making it so that
preparing for the David Pakman show the
day before is increasingly a futile
effort where we might
five six really usually we have 15 or 20
possible stories for the next day and
then something happens at 3 a.m.
sometimes on Twitter and the entire show
is sort of upended and along these lines
we continue to learn more about former
disgraced ashamed national security
adviser Michael Flynn we knew so to
catch you up very quickly without
redoing the entire story Michael Flynn
was Donald Trump's completely bogus
national security adviser and we learned
that Michael Flynn lied to Mike Pence
and then Mike Pence lied and many many
people lied about whether or not Flynn
had discussed sanctions Russian
sanctions with the Russian ambassador to
the United States in the period between
November 8th and January 20th okay so
there were sort of two problems there
one was well why would Flynn be
describing sanctions there's this sort
of understanding that we have one
president at a time and someone who is
the unconfirmed nominee for a
president-elect should not be having
conversations about Russian sanctions
that's number one but then Flynn lied
about it okay and then Mike Pence said
Oh Mike Flynn didn't have those
conversations it was all lies okay Flynn
resigned what we're now learning and
there's an article in The Washington
Post which we're going to dig into in
detail next week on the show is that
Michael Flynn appears to have also lied
to the FBI and in in conversation with
the FBI about what he did or didn't say
with the Russian ambassador he denied
having talked about those Russian
sanctions and we've been speculating or
sort of wondering could there be
criminal charges somewhere in here as
far as Michael Flynn is concerned now
that we've learned that Flynn Flynn has
lied to the FBI this has escalated even
more now of course Trump still going to
write the entire thing off of some as
some kind of conspiracy to as Trump said
distract from Hillary having lost who's
still talking about Hillary having lost
if you're almost calling more attention
to it if that's the
idea or that if this is all a cover-up
for pizza gate or whatever increasingly
it's it's clear that Michael Flynn may
indeed have committed a crime and if
that's the case then that needs to be
fully fully and properly investigated no
question about it big thank you to John
Steffes John Steffes who has just signed
up for membership at david pakman.com
slash membership you can read about the
benefits there mostly were funded by
membership and you can use the coupon
code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount the
progressive voice has sent a super chat
for two US dollars saying I'm a new
progressive news show could you help me
I don't know how to address that it's
ideal if there's some kind of specific
question but if I could give general
advice to progressive news shows number
one content is king focus on content and
number two what is number two I don't
know it's really just focus on content
that's that's really sort of the the key
thing all right let's continue with a
couple other stories and before I do
that a big thank you to Joanne yo macka
Joanne yo macka has just signed up at
david pakman.com slash membership using
the coupon code
I voted 17 which saves you 40% and just
very one small other detour before I get
into the Trump approval rating stuff you
know the the cut is it really how old
are the people in the comments who are
either calling me a [ __ ] Chuck for
eyes I mean it feels like we're we're in
third grade here if this is truly what
your life has has become going on the
internet and attempting to call
attention to yourself by calling people
on the internet Chuck and [ __ ] I truly
feel sorry for you I mean I can't even
get mad I genuinely and if Benedictus
don't I'm back I think I just got
disconnected I apologize about that I
don't know what's going on with the
connection
it seems to have gone down but I believe
that I'm back I don't know okay Trump's
approval rating Pew Research Center says
Trump's approval rating has fallen off
the cliff down to 39% Rasmussen who
tends to be more friendly to Republicans
says Trump's approval rating has
skyrocketed to 55 percent I tend to just
follow the Gallup daily tracking poll
the Gallup daily tracking poll has
basically been done for I think it's
like 40 years or something like that and
that's the one that I tend to follow and
along that that note let's pull it up
what it it pull up what it is
daily presidential tracking because that
one has basically been been slightly
trailing off for Trump and let's see
where it is today I don't know for
whatever reason I'm having a hard time
pulling that up on my computer where is
the daily tracking poll I don't know so
whether it's 39 or 55 is a major
difference here's why it matters and a
lot of piece on this number one there's
people who say the polls got the
election wrong so why would we pay any
attention to polls today absolutely
wrong on multiple fronts number one the
election polls were not wrong I mean
that they generally had Hillary Clinton
ahead in the national popular vote by
around 2 to 4 percent she ended up
winning by about 3 points in the in the
national popular vote
so the polls were right about that and
they were within the margin of error in
those three states in which a total of
77 thousand votes gave the election to
Donald Trump okay so if the if you're
starting off with the premise that the
election polls were wrong
thus anything the election polls were
not really wrong in a sort of
mathematical methodological sense
further approval rating is much
different you don't need a likely voter
model in the same way that you do people
could have an opinion of who they would
vote for if they voted and that would be
separate from is that person actually
going to vote and since we only had
roughly 50 percent voter turnout the the
assessing of who is actually going to
vote is really really important
presidential approval is a totally
different thing but
reason it matters is Trump started with
one of the lowest approval ratings of
any recent president it took him only
eight days to get to fifty percent
disapproval for comparison it took our
prior four presidents anywhere from I
think it's like six hundred to thirteen
hundred days to get to a point of fifty
percent disapproval
if Trump's approval rating continues to
slide as we start getting into the 2018
midterms which remember all 435 House
seats in the House of Representatives
are up for re-election every two years
you are going to start to see
Republicans jumping ship because
mathematically it's going to start to
become a liability to be on the Trump
train so to speak and it's going to
potentially be advantageous to them to
to get away from that I see a few people
saying that as of February 16th the
gallup tracking poll has Trump at 38% it
that if that's true that's crazy I
haven't seen that I can't independently
confirm that but if that's true that's
absolutely crazy so that's my thought on
the Trump approval rating I would take a
look at the Gallup daily tracking poll
we've got a $5 Super chat from mr. Corin
who says David your thoughts on having
some sort of non government oversight
companies could opt into and gain a way
to appeal to thoughtful consumers at a
glance there's a number of those already
I don't want to name any because some of
them I I don't think do a particularly
good job but there are a lot of
different companies and you can google
this organizations that claim to and you
know it'd be up to you to figure out
whether their claims are believable to
you to say hey we've established that
these companies are they have upstanding
business practices etc etc okay I am
gonna ban one person here if I can
because you know what I don't it doesn't
even seem like I can ban people from my
phone which is really really unfortunate
let's see if I can do it from the from
the computer because there are some
serious trolls that I I don't really
mine the trolling too much yeah I've
lost my ability to be
people I'm not even logged in with the
right account to my stream unfortunately
let's see if I can switch over here if
you're just gonna post comment after
comment after comment and fill the chat
we really can't do that okay all right
now I've got my permissions block and
the user who goes by the name free
speech has been has been banned call me
a [ __ ] you know whatever but but if
you're gonna just go one after another
it's just going to be a major major
distraction all right remember coupon
code
I voted 17 you can sign up at david
pakman.com slash membership live thank
yous and shout outs and of course
everybody who signs up gets instant
access to the bonus show which we do
every single day just for our
subscribers ok not that this is going to
be surprising to many of the subscribers
to our channel but it appears as though
Donald Trump may have sort of not been
totally upfront about his academic
record at a Wharton School of Business
at the University of Pennsylvania
there's an article from philly.com and
Donald Trump has claimed to be sort of a
real Ivy League guy brilliant guy with
just a stunning academic record and he's
been claiming that he was a top student
in his class all the way back from 1973
there was a New York Times profile in 73
which said hey Trump graduated first in
his class but that wasn't actually
attributed to anything in particular and
then in 1976 so three years later there
was another New York Times profile where
it also said oh this guy Donald Trump at
the time much less well-known graduated
first in his class and it sort of been
repeated since and often the 1973 and
1976 articles are cited as the source of
that but now people have actually
started looking at the records and
there's no evidence whatsoever that
Donald Trump graduated at the top of his
class
so I won't get into all the details now
because we're going to do the story
fully and properly next week
but is anybody I mean in the comments
let me know is anybody sir what anybody
be shocked to hear that Donald Trump's
claims about academic achievement may
have been overblown I mean it's not
clear the guy can read beyond a fourth
or fifth grade level so to me it's
absolutely and completely unsurprising
and if you actually look just one more
bit of data if you look at the 1968
commencement program from the University
of Pennsylvania Trump is not listed
among anybody who graduated with honors
among anybody who got other Awards etc
so Trump's nowhere as far as that goes
okay not surprising to me in absolutely
any way big thank you to to new David
Pakman show members who signed up at
david pakman.com slash membership in the
last few days
number one Jorge Torres and number two
Jerry Hickel thank you to both of you
both using the coupon code
I voted 17 the great thing about the
coupon code is you pay less but you
still get everything that you would get
paying full price so I don't I'm not an
expert in this type of thing but if you
can pay less and get all the same stuff
that sounds pretty good a few people
have pointed me to a I was going to say
a eggs list post but I'm actually going
to say a screen shot of a craigslist
post which claims to be seeking pro
Trump rally attendees for Donald Trump's
rally that he's doing tomorrow and it's
offering either a complimentary gift or
a cash voucher so I've not looked into
this yet and if you want to help me with
some of the background research on this
what this is implying is that for this
very strange rally it's almost like the
campaign is still going on for Trump
common thing that authoritarian
dictatorial types like to do which is
even when they're in power they keep
doing rallies as if they're still
campaigning what if true if this is a
legitimate craigslist post it appears as
though people are being offered money to
show up and
a protest or not necessarily protest but
just sort of like rally in favor of
Donald Trump so we're gonna be looking
into that and we'll see what what we can
find out about that between now and our
next show we've got a $5 super chat from
the progressive voice saying I'm new on
the scene trying to get my name out
there I'm sure you were in this position
in 2010 what did you do to grow can I
get a shout out well what I did was I
became very consistent and reliable so
we developed when at the time we didn't
have a lot of broadcast affiliates I
knew that showing up is half or more of
the battle so that if we could put
together a reliable schedule for a show
which I think in 2010 was only twice a
week or something like that
we would be able to to do quite well and
indeed that was sort of like the the
number one thing that that I think made
a big difference
excuse me I'm just gonna have to ban a
couple other people here I'm doing the
best I can to keep up with the chat
there is just a lot of really crazy
stuff that's going on in the chat and
we've got eight hundred and thirty
people on the livestream which is great
even if only half of one percent of
those our unsub 'el trolls that's still
four to five people and so that that's
something that's going to require some
attention okay other stories that I'm
going to be dealing with next week on
the show there's a very interesting
article on NPR which you can search for
the title is as presidents live longer
doctors debate whether to test for
dementia I know that it sounds like this
is just related to to Donald Trump and
obviously seeing what's going on with
Donald Trump makes us question whether
he might be mentally ill have early
early onset but rather early stage
Alzheimer's or some kind of dementia
whether he just can't read that well
whether he's emotionally unstable
whatever and there are doctors now who
are saying listen Donald Donald Trump is
making us think of this because
of his erratic behavior yes but also
because of his he's the oldest president
to ever be inaugurated in the United
States and the longer people live the
more that it should be known whether we
have people here who are of diminished
cognitive capacity and this is a story
that we're going to be looking at and
you know the other thing that is is
relevant here is you would say well you
just have the doctor tell you the
president's doctor will tell us whether
everything's okay
let me say two words for for you to
remind you of why that's not possible
Harold Bornstein this is Trump's doctor
who we learned in five minutes with
Trump reportedly waiting outside in a
limo threw together a completely
hyperbolic and bogus letter about Donald
Trump's health saying Trump would be the
healthiest president ever inaugurated
how could dr. Harold Bornstein know that
without having examined every other
president I mean it was just totally
laughable so we can't even really trust
medical professionals to be completely
honest and reliable as far as this goes
and indeed I I think that there's
something something to this and it would
be really a good thing for us to know
are we are there people here who are
diminished cognitive capacity because of
some condition that they might have okay
a few people saying David you're talking
about membership but what's included in
membership can you explain that
I'll just take 20 seconds to explain
that if you have a membership instead of
having these three to five-minute clips
on YouTube every single day much earlier
than the YouTube clips go live you get
the full hour TV show - the commercials
which works out to about 51 minutes okay
every single day in addition to that
every day we do a bonus show it's
roughly 15 minutes sometimes it goes 20
and we do additional stories more behind
the scenes scene stuff etc etc okay so
that's something else that you get as a
David Pakman show member you also get an
archive that goes all the way back to
the first shows in 2005 I hesitate to
even mention that because those shows
are pretty embarrassingly bad but you
know there
available normally only the last eight
podcasts are available but our paid
members can go all the way back to the
first shows so those are a few of the
things that are available will also do
sort of quarterly or every few months
we'll do a members-only video conference
where we people can connect a Skype in
and talk to the staff ask questions etc
all right so those are the few few of
the things that are available I'm going
to be covering next week the story of
the FBI arresting a neo-nazi who was
planning a Dylan roof style massacre at
none other location than a synagogue and
you know it got some coverage but again
this is the this this is a story that
it's not going to be that appealing to
people that are completely committed to
the idea that only Muslims are a problem
when it comes to terrorism and I wish
that people didn't get so upset when I
just kind of laid out the reality when
it comes to this and so here's the truth
right worldwide it is Muslim men who are
the most common perpetrators of acts of
terror in the United States its
american-born white men that are the
most common perpetrators of acts of
terror and I recently in a in a course
that I'm doing with the anti-defamation
league we actually had an expert come in
they have experts who have come in to
talk to us about Islamic terror and we
had that course and we also had an
expert come in to talk to us about white
nationalist terror and this includes a
bunch of different groups so under white
nationalist terror you've got official
groups like the KKK you have white
nationalists those are more people like
Richard Spencer who at least publicly
say as he told me in our interview that
they are against physical violence you
have Aryan prison gangs and you might
say well why is that relevant they're
only in prison not true actually the
activities of Aryan prison gangs are
overlapping into the sort of world at
large
and so there's a whole bunch of
different groups in any case the the
right-wing terror of which white
nationalist white supremacist terror is
a part so called patriot movement is
another aspect of that anti-government
right wingers are another part of
domestic right-wing terror it's actually
the most common source of terrorist acts
in the United States there seem to be a
lot of people on either side committed
to only one narrative you have some
people on the Left who don't want to at
all talk about the fact that worldwide
Muslim men are the number one
perpetrators of terrorist acts but then
you have people on the right who want to
pretend like Trump's Muslim majority
immigration ban is the solution to
prepare in the United States even though
immigrants and refugees from the listed
countries haven't actually come over and
committed acts of terror and pretend
like we just don't have to worry about
american-born white dudes both of these
views are completely unproductive
fundamentally because they're inaccurate
and if you're not going to start with
the facts it's gonna be really really
tough to have a good conversation so
we're going to dig into this story
absolutely
next week on the program the FBI
arresting a neo-nazi planning an attack
in the style of Dylan roof there's a few
super chats I want to get to there's a
$5 super chat from sy Fox who says we
should be more focused on mental health
in this country anyway it is laughable
how the state of our mental health
knowledge is quite question mark I guess
the it's is it laughable how the state
of our mental health knowledge is I'm
struggling a little bit with the syntax
of this question but our our lack of
awareness of the ways in which mental
health is pervading many areas of
society I think is absolutely I don't
know that ID ID use the term laughable
but maybe sad
chimpanzee a five dollar super chat
saying my hands are better than Trump's
because they give you $5.00 that is true
that is true and there is absolutely no
no way around that
okay people keep talking to me about
that I should answer the question from
super [ __ ] I don't know who or what
super [ __ ] is and I don't know what the
question is but maybe if a couple people
can repeat it this the chat is moving so
fast that it's
for me to keep up with it so let me know
what that is Lu Chu has sent a five
Canadian dollar super chat with no
question thank you for that is there
anybody here who can explain to me what
the question is from from super [ __ ]
which is an interesting name I'm
scrolling and I'm not oh let's see here
it is David do you think it's offensive
to compare Hitler and Trump and cheapens
what Jews went through many Jewish
leaders speak out against the comparison
thanks David okay perfectly good
question
for a long time I've spoken out against
making allusions or likening things to
Nazis or Hitler or the Holocaust merely
for the sake of sort of being
provocative particularly when it's not
accurate so to say Trump is Hitler to me
seems wrong because right now it just
doesn't seem like there's really a fair
comparison there what I think is
perfectly reasonable to do and let me
actually I want to pull up the specific
name because I want to have clarity this
evening there is a professor who is
named Timothy Snyder from Yale okay and
I'm trying to get him on the show
because he recently did an interview
that is very very interesting and I
think there are people already in the
comments who are starting to point to
what I'm about to get to Timothy Snyder
the Yale professor has spoken out and
his area of expertise is Europe world
war one world war two and the period
between world wars one and two he has
pointed out that there are many
similarities between what is going on in
the United States with Donald Trump the
rise of the alt-right the authoritarian
pseudo populist rhetoric there are
similarities empirical historical
similarities between the pre-world War
two ERA and what is going on right now
to be clear that's not saying that Trump
is Hitler it's not even close to saying
that Donald Trump is Hitler and I
that we need to be a little more
thoughtful is it offensive to compare
stuff to Hitler I don't know you know I
tend not to use the term offensive so
loosely because it often doesn't have
that that much real meaning what does it
really mean to say something is
offensive but so I think we should be
paying attention to what Timothy Snyder
is saying okay let me give a few Thank
You shoutouts as people have been
signing up in droves while I've been
talking here at david pakman.com slash
membership number one diana Dwyer queer
queer a queer a Diana that part I'm sure
of thank you for signing up at david
pakman.com slash membership thank you to
kyle Dickinson who has also created a
subscription at david pakman.com slash
membership with the coupon code
I voted 17 which gives you 40% off ok so
that I think I've gone basically through
most of what we're going to be talking
about as of right now next week on the
first or second shows of the week I am
this story keeps getting pushed back
this is sort of a longer story and
segment producer Noah Ferguson I think
maybe is somebody who could who could
help with some of the background
research on this there is a strategy
that can be employed to destroy fake
news and I addressed fake and use a
little bit yesterday and we've talked
about how the the blatant actual fake
news right not using the word fake news
to talk about news we don't like but
actual fake satirical deliberately just
made-up stories right
they've been leaning left since the
inauguration of Donald Trump and we
talked about that yesterday a little bit
but there is actually a strategy that's
really effective for dealing with fake
news which is fake news exists because
it's profitable and their stories about
Eastern European countries where the
average wage is like $400 u.s. dollars a
month and there's fake news operations
that are making you know 10 or 20 or
even 30 times that on a monthly basis
and the reason that's happening is
mostly not be
advertisers are saying hey I'm gonna buy
ads on a fake news website but rather
because they're advertising through ad
networks and they may not even know that
their ads are showing up on some of
these fake news sites and it's been a
super effective campaign when you're on
one of these sites and you see an ad for
a company where you say sort of seems
like a respectable company I'm surprised
that they would be advertising on this
site you take a screenshot of it and
then you start tweeting it to the
company and the pressure that has been
put on a lot of these companies because
they didn't even know that their ad was
showing up on these websites many of
them have gone and said we are pulling
our ads from those websites Warby Parker
which by the way these people always
laugh they say in the war B port Parker
ad that you do David you don't wear your
Warby Parker glasses because my contacts
ripped yesterday and I have to wait a
few days for replacements I'm wearing my
Warby Parker glasses Warby Parker's ads
were showing up on Breitbart they didn't
know wasn't deliberate people shamed
them publicly and they pulled the
advertising okay okay we have a 50 and
okay well I don't know what currency and
okay is that can't possibly be a North
Korean currency right I don't know what
I don't even know how many dollars 50
and OK's is the question is from t TV 5
David should the Department of Justice
move to prosecute Dave Rubin for the
murder of reason this was worth it to me
very funny I am genuinely curious what n
okay what currency Oh Norwegian kroner
does anybody know how much fifty
Norwegian kroner is in American dollars
I don't I don't know offhand
Lyle frappe ear sending a three Canadian
dollar super chat saying don't you find
Shirley phelps-roper from the Westboro
Baptist Church resembles Kellyanne
Conway never thought about that before
but not really no I I don't I don't
actually see that okay 50 Norwegian
kroner is two US dollars I saw 50 and
thought I don't know I know that the
economies are pretty
wrong over there somebody else saying
that it's six US dollars okay
very very funny one Norwegian krone
equals twelve US cents which is
interesting all right well I'm glad that
glad glad that that was worth it for you
okay Robert little thank you for signing
up at david pakman.com slash membership
Robert used the coupon code
I voted 17 which saves you 40% off of
the cost of membership okay last thing I
want to mention for next week's programs
people have been asking me to talk about
something called I think I need to raise
my chair I'm a little low aren't I
tax resistance okay and tax resistance
as I understand it and I will admit I
have not prepared in detail for doing
this story next week tax resistance is
basically refusing to pay taxes because
you're opposed to the government that's
imposing the tax and of course if you
truly don't pay taxes period and you
should be paying taxes you typically end
up in jail at least if you're caught but
there's a strategy which can be employed
which is if you're a w-2 employee when
you sign up when you get hired not sign
up when you sign up to work when you get
hired and go through the the hiring
process you tell your employer how much
money you want them to withhold from
your check and there's the idea that if
everybody adjusted their withholding so
that you're not getting any money taken
out during the year yes at the end of
the year you file your taxes and then
you still end up having to write a check
for what you would have paid throughout
the year but the idea being if everybody
did this if everybody withheld their tax
withholdings throughout the entire year
it would deprive the government of the
money that they need to operate okay
that's sort of the idea and we're gonna
be looking into I do want to talk about
this it's a very very interesting idea I
actually don't know whether
mathematically it would
I don't know if it's if it's possible
for logistical reasons like maybe as a
w-2 employee you are supposed to be
paying some minimum on a quarterly basis
I'm not really sure so we're gonna be
looking into that just taking a quick
look at the chat to see if there is some
significant kind of drama that's going
on there things sort of sort of seem
seem okay right now a few other notes
number one if you have any interview
suggestions I would say that at this
point half or more of our interviews are
suggestions from the audience if you
have any suggestions you can always
email me david at david pakman.com and
we will look into them we are doing more
and more of these two-part interviews
which people seem to be liking so far we
did one with Peter Boghossian last week
we have a couple more scheduled coming
up and we actually have some fantastic
interviews coming up for you and I was
sort of hesitant before we started doing
the two part interview thing to do
longer interviews to do interviews with
certain people because the conversations
just can't be had in 12 minutes which is
what we often had but now that we're
extending interview segments over two
days there's a lot of people were going
to be able to talk to next week we are
going to have Luke Vargas
reporting in from Mexico actually
talking to companies about what the the
impact on them would be of some of the
policies that Donald Trump is proposing
etc we're also going to talk to Bill o
Goolsbee on Wednesday the 22nd he's an
expert on gerrymandering and the history
of gerrymandering I think it's gonna be
absolutely fascinating and then on
Thursday we will be interviewing Stefan
I believe the right pronunciation of his
last name is Gannett or a guy Anette he
did a reddit AMA
recently very interesting he's an expert
on obesity and metabolism and the
history of dieting and whatnot and then
the following week this is going to be a
two-part interview with Marcelo gleiser
who
is going to talk to us about the
neuroscience of morality so not the not
whether science can tell us about
morality but specifically the
neuroscience of morality and how the
brain is impacted by that $5 super chat
from Jerry Hickel who says David wanted
to ask you if you think Donald Trump may
have simply not matured to be an adult
due to his privileged upbringing yeah
we've talked about that there's no doubt
that some aspect of what is going on
with Trump is just not having had to end
or what sort of the average non
billionaire has to endure or non
millionaire as well I think that there's
absolutely something to that okay some
people talking about something that
Brody Andrew Mulligan said people
reacting to that although I can't
actually tell what that is scary plague
sends a super chat asking my thoughts on
the upcoming Bundy trial I don't know
much about it I don't know what what
exactly is is going on with that but I
am interested to to find out more about
it and that that that is I think we're
having some kind of connection problem
like my laptop has completely imploded
at this point from the stream so I think
this is probably a good time to call it
thanks to everybody who signed up at
david pakman.com slash membership the
coupon code will work even after I
disconnect I voted 17 were mostly funded
by you so I do hope you'll check out
membership and we'll do another live
stream very very soon